very much unfortunately we do have to
talk about the coronavirus because the
u.s just recorded its worst week for new
cases since this pandemic began
more than half a million new coveted
infections numbers are rising in 43
states
and roughly one-third of all new cases
are coming from the midwest
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in minneapolis david
officials in that part of the country
are sounding a lot more worried these
days
they are it is below freezing here in
minnesota and 19
hospitalizations are at a record high in
fact the governor
is asking people on both sides of the
political spectrum
not to attend political rallies leading
up to election day
i want to start this morning in
wisconsin the state right next door
where the situation is dire
the state of wisconsin set new records
for cases
hospitalizations and deaths yesterday
and now a fifth patient is being treated
at a field hospital
set up outside of milwaukee across the
midwest
seven states are reporting a record
number of coronavirus hospitalizations
illinois is now averaging more new
coronavirus cases
per day than at any other point in the
pandemic
and in chicago the daily increase in
covid related hospitalizations
has more than doubled since october
began
so the governor is now shutting down all
indoor dining
starting this friday chicago seemed to
have this more under control
than other regions of illinois but
that's no longer the case
there are stories of hope and we want
you to hear them meet carmen lairma
she's 52 years old a community leader
from milwaukee
she was hospitalized with coronavirus in
july
she had passed out at home she says when
she woke up she was in the hospital
and she was already hooked up to
breathing machines
they said to me you know you're lucky
you have
a guardian angel watching over you
because your body oxygen was at 31
when you got here that is to be
brain dead or on a coma carmen spent 45
days on a ventilator in the icu
she only had minor underlying conditions
like high blood pressure
but the virus permanently damaged her
lungs
the doctors told her she needed a double
lung transplant
and just last week carmen had a
successful operation
but she has a long road to recovery you
think this is a joke you think though
this is not oh it's just like the virus
or it's like the flu no
it's not like flu it doesn't feel like a
flu i was pretty healthy
i was pretty healthy and look at me
you know contact tracing works carmen
got a call from her local health
department
saying she had been exposed to someone
who had the virus so she should
quarantine and get tested
and right around then she started
feeling sick real quick we have news on
the vaccine front
pfizer says they're not going to have
the results of their vaccine trial
before the election but they are still
expecting to ask the fda for
an emergency youth authorization order
to get it into use by the end of
november
gail all right david still thinking
about carmen's story she's very lucky
thank you very